the bitcoin price continues to go up
it's up about 35 over the last couple of
weeks and more people keep asking me why
the hell is the price increasing one of
the main drivers is that there's a brand
new buyer in the market the terra
ecosystem using the luna foundation's
reserves they claim that they are going
to buy up to 10 billion dollars worth of
bitcoin now price of any asset is based
on supply and demand the supply of
bitcoin is known with certainty both
today and into the future but the demand
continues to fluctuate and whenever you
have somebody step into the market and
spend billions of dollars to buy bitcoin
of course the price is going to go up to
accommodate everyone the beauty of the
bitcoin blockchain is that we can
actually look on chain we can see the
wallet of exactly who is buying and how
much they have here's the wallet that
the luna foundation is using and we can
see that they currently have tens of
thousands of bitcoins sitting in that
wallet over a billion dollars we then
can actually look at individual
transactions and you can see right here
that they're actually buying the bitcoin
from that wallet if we go ahead and we
ask ourselves why exactly are they doing
this well do quan recently had a great
way of putting it he stated a couple of
reasons but simply bitcoin is the only
hard reserve asset that's been proven
out of the digital currencies it's very
difficult for somebody in crypto to
question bitcoin and ultimately what the
terra ecosystem is doing is they're
taking their stablecoin known as ust and
they're backing it with bitcoin they're
taking the reserves for that stablecoin
and they're just buying bitcoin right
now they have about three billion
dollars that they're going to convert
into bitcoin and over time it'll be 10
billion dollars in total if we then go
ahead and we take a look how exactly are
they doing this how hard is it well kyle
from three arrows capital put it
perfectly he said i can tell some of you
have not executed size of trades before
but let me tell you buying 125 million
dollars a day of bitcoin for three
months is a lot this is an incredible
feat to watch them pull this off there
is a persistent buyer in the market and
they're not just coming in with five or
ten dollars they're coming in with a
hundred plus million dollars a day
for months
the bitcoin price has to react if we
then go ahead and we take a look at this
other tweet it says that tara and the
luna foundation are carrying the bitcoin
bull market on its shoulders the more
that the ust stable coin grows the more
senior edge that's used to buy bitcoin
as you buy more bitcoin the bitcoin
price goes up as the bitcoin price goes
up there's more backing for ust which
leads to more ust growth ust's
unstoppable programmable money backed by
the world's hardest asset and as doe
quan said long live bitcoin ultimately
what we're watching is the price is
going up because there's increased
demand the biggest increase in the
demand is coming from terra luna and do
kwan over time people will start to
realize supply and demand drives every
asset and when you increase demand of a
fixed supply asset the price has to go
up hey you did you like this video great
we make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time